so you probably know by now that a great  pair of shoes is the anchor to any  outfit but if your shoes aren't tied  properly and they come undone at that  critical moment it's all a waste here's  a knot that'll make sure that once you  tie them in the morning  you're said all day this is sometimes  called a Windsor knot or a surgeon's  knot and it's extremely simple to tie  you just loop over the top and then loop  over a second time and pull it as tight  as you want this is gonna be the base  for the knot you then make a loop bring  the other lace around and pull through  but instead of tightening like you're  probably used to you bring this knot  over and under one more time then you  pull tight  you bring the laces to whatever length  you want and you notice they sit flat  and straight across the top and the  knots nice and small it doesn't create  any bulk here it is all the way through  in case you missed it  and there you go the only knot you'll  ever need